our youtubers never late Frodo Baggins
no gonna say the straight up upfront yes
this game came out over a year ago so
there's nothing that I can really add
that hasn't been said already but if you
want to know my opinion I'm Legend of
Zelda Brothers wild here you go and if
you want to help me out because
YouTube's just boning a lot of people
right now if you're subscribed to me
also click that little bell icon because
apparently that's how you see my videos
because YouTube's like just cuz you
subscribe doesn't really mean you want
to watch them right paraphrasing that's
the gist so you've probably heard that
from a lot of youtubers a lot of people
are saying that but that's because they
have to we have to out of the way let's
talk about Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild
[Music]
legend of zelda breath of a while the
legend yourself impressive the wild came
out for the WiiU and the switch it was a
port to the switch from the Wii U
because we II was just losing momentum
they're like alright we're gonna put
that for our new system very sweet
launch title but I was like I'm gonna
hold out on this wish because well I
bought it with you I fell for that [ __ ]
before we'll see how it goes so I got
brothers a while for the Wii U and
played it played a lot of it love about
this game is after link wakes up he's
like I have amnesia and this dude's like
well you calamity Ganon has taken over
Hyrule Castle and then you have a
tutorial that doesn't really feel like a
tutorial I can't praise this game enough
tutorials are ball numbing ly boring
this tutorial didn't feel like a
tutorial generally speaking you do
everything in the tutorial area that you
do out there most things anyway it's a
smaller sandbox of the bigger sandbox
the biggest things you do is you do find
these abilities that stick with you
throughout the game bombs square bombs
don't roll down hills lemons you into
Magneto the other stops time for an item
so you can beat the piss out of it and
then all the energy transfers to it
immediately just flies you later upgrade
these items to be a little more
effective point is most shrines you run
across it have puzzles deal with these
abilities or the bow and arrow might
might use the bone arrow after that have
fun the world is your oyster you can do
anything and go anywhere you can
actually go straight to hyrule castle
and take on calamity again and
immediately you beat the game within
like an hour in most cases if you try
that you will get your dick kicked in up
through your throat but you can drive
point is the execution of this tutorial
deserves props and though the game does
hurt you in certain directions were good
go here lose aura stuff you don't have
to go there my brother was like I did
death Mountain first I don't know how he
did that but he did see the fort divine
beast you go into in this game they do
serve as Zelda dungeons but there are
only four of them and at first I was
like 4 dungeons that's it you got to
just find these shrines and then solve
the puzzles of the shrines at first
knee-jerk reaction I just didn't like
that I like the traditional Zelda
dungeons I felt like that was just taken
away from him like you took away the
puzzle element but they actually didn't
take away the puzzle element if you take
a beat and just kind of think about it
is really if you look at the Zelda
dungeons the Zelda dungeons are a series
of puzzles that work together in tandem
to create one big dungeon it just took
those dungeons with all those puzzles
and individualize the puzzles and spread
them around Hyrule and other shrines you
got to look for still have the puzzle
element with the shrines you just have
to search for them more sometimes the
puzzle is just finding the shrine
because some of these shrines are hard
to find but every
shrine you beat you get a spirit orb you
get four of those spirit orbs you get a
heart container and they can't really
overemphasize how fun it is to search
for shrines so many days just found
myself for hours walking around the
landscape of Hyrule looking for shrines
because I look at my map I'm like
there's no shrine there there probably
is though I haven't mapped it so let's
go find it in terms of battle battle is
actually pretty familiar lock on to the
enemy dodge right dodge left flip
backwards swing your sword sweeps or no
I mean the moves are pretty much the
same if an enemies gonna hit at you if
you dodge at the right time it'll slow
down you can just do a flurry and just
beat the smack out of I'm finding that
sweet moment is pretty important in
beating the hard enemies okay let me you
get the patterns down so really they're
not a problem now at first when you meet
a lion although in terms of battle I
felt like some of the enemies were being
punks we'll take the lion / example
probably lie now but I called them
Lionel like Lionel I ended up calling
them Lionel Luthor's when I was on
ponies when you get their charges down
the dodging down what they'll do is
they'll run past you and the camera
swings around to where now you probably
need to hold back in order to jump for
the next attack but back it's no longer
back it's actually the cameras kind of
excused so back is left and then you get
smacked because you don't dodge
correctly but like the computer was
using the camera trickery as a trick to
get a hit off on me and I felt like that
was kind of Punk biggest differences the
shield swords bows that you find they
break you use them enough it'll take
damage they take damage they will break
so when you beat an enemy pick up their
weapon you need a lot of swords you need
a lot of shields whether the game goes
on you find more powerful swords and
shields and you always run into that
feeling of if only I had one more slot
you do find these little [ __ ] there are
hundreds of them in this world but you
can trade in their seeds get more slots
for a sword shield or bow I ended up
with a lot of weapon slots and I always
ran into that feeling if only I had one
more because like anything financial
income days of the week you adapt it
always feels like you don't have enough
days in the week to do what you need to
do no matter how many days you actually
have to do it human beings are very good
at adapting to making sure they don't
actually end up having an excess of
anything they probably need an excess of
you also have armored base bugs outfit
buffs whether it be you have to have
your gear for cold when you're climbing
the mountains or your gear to cool down
when you're in the desert or your gear
for battle or maybe the gear you have
just looks cool these like the aesthetic
appeal of it so you just want to wear it
I like the fact that link isn't locked
into one outfit there are a lot more
heart containers in this game because
you're actually probably the Wii
just blink like his leg didn't mean to
but link can't take as many hits in this
game as he usually can so it's very
important to buff up your armor or learn
to dodge cooking is a very important
thing in here you different meats
seasonings mushrooms apples I said
mushrooms I hate mushroom but for this
game mushrooms work for a filler and you
cook them and you get a meal that'll
replenish hearts and that's all fine and
dandy but if you're looking for hearts
you just get a hearty radish and cook
one of those and just one hearty radish
and you'll get a meal that will
replenish all your hearts plus three but
you need stamina that's fine endure a
carrot does the same thing you cook one
indirect hair is fine brillant cooking
comes into play if you need armor buffs
or attack buffs that's where the cooking
recipes come in so for hearts once you
get hearty radishes there's also about
the first fairy fountain there's one
right over there in the corner every
time you go there you can just pluck it
like the fun of cooking lost its luster
Rose like I know what I need I do feel
like the music in this game left me a
little wanting I was looking forward to
some of the Zelda themes playing while I
was out there on my adventure the music
is really ambient music
it does totally work for the sake of
ambiance but I can't really think of any
themes in this game to dunt dunt I can't
think of that like if they were to come
out with another anniversary mix CD like
they did with Skyward Sword don't know
any songs from this game that I would
want in that say day when you're writing
Hyrule Castle the theme is pretty sweet
and you do hear some of the Zelda theme
in there so you're some inspiration and
variants of older Zelda music throughout
in places when you're hanging out in
Death Mountain that song is actually the
last dungeon in the original Zelda oh
you just listen to his example I do like
that there are variants but there was no
theme that really got my blood Jack
maybe in one of the patches you can
unlock music or something but I cannot
speak highly enough of the games layout
just a geographical appeal you look
around this world it is alive the draw
distance literally seems like it goes
from one end of a Hyrule to the other so
watch what I had so much fun just
running around searching for stuff maybe
I was searching for a shrine maybe I'm
searching for a memory I get to memories
in a second but any open-world game that
can genuinely make your experience in
the world fun for the sake of just being
in the world that's the win right there
you don't want your game to feel like a
grind and breath of the wild never felt
like a grind to me it is a completionist
paradise I'm not
completionists yeah the memories are a
very important thing there are these
memories in your chicest life it's
pretty much your cell phone and there
are pictures of locations you have to
find these locations that these pictures
were taken you go there and it'll unlock
a memory of what happened 100 years ago
Link's friendship with Zelda what
happened how they lost without you
finding the memories the story really
does leave you wanting because it's
really there's not a story I was just
really impressed at how I could look at
this picture and be like alright well
those are the Garuda Mountains right
there that means that's that forest
which means that part is probably
probably somewhere around there so let's
look around a while I found it every
picture I was able to look at and be
like alright let's figure out where it
is and I figured it out it's because the
makers of this game made a world that
feels very different based on the
regions if I was to look at a picture
from a part of most any open-world game
would be like I don't know exactly where
that is but for breath of the wild it's
doable
except that picture because it's one
forest and whatever I googled it it's
one part of one force you know how many
forests there are in this game really
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild is
the Zelda game that pushes The Legend of
Zelda
forward it pushes it to the next level
there's a lot to do there's a lot to
unlock a lot to unpack a lot to upgrade
a lot to search for a lot to find
however the game is not too overly
complicated rather the wild never felt
daunting it always encouraged me to go
further it's not excessively complicated
it's accessible yet complex this game
was 85 hours of pure enjoyment and
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild is
awesome tacular
and that is just for the WiiU so for a
beat breath of the wild I got to switch
the next day since I had a switch I was
like I might as well get breath of the
wild for the sweat and I literally
replayed it again the day after I had
beaten breath of the wild for my Wii U
the fun the adventure the weapons the
outfits the gear the upgrades all the
cooking recipes or the hardy radishes
the shrines the divine beast the hours
the days put into it all happened to get
in fact on my switch I have more than I
actually had on my wii u I played it
again immediately back to back because
of the wild made me feel like a kid
again it made me feel like I was on an
adventure in a way very few games these
days do so if you haven't picked it up
yet I encourage you to if you have
picked it up if you played it if you've
beaten it if you have completed all of
it props to you I hope you're having fun
it's a Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild have you played it why did you
think about it whatever your thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more and again if you can after
subscribing click that bell icons why
does YouTube gotta mess with a good
thing no help
[Music]